are we live
we are live it's not how I started the
show that's how I reset that's my babble
are we in golf give me the give me what
do we start this all right kids we're
back man we're here in the scum and
villainy Cantina no donations tonight
man just kick back and enjoy the show
gonna be very informative because we've
got super guests man we've got
stupendous we've got the most powerful
man in comics to talk to tonight we're
going to talk to him right away but
before we do that how are you good for
I'm doing all right man life life like
this did you find a cure like here we
were looking yeah and it turns out it's
not in peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches I thought it might have been
in cheeseburgers and now I'm trying to
work my way through chicken sandwiches
I'm gonna find the cure within fast food
I had the I had high hopes cuz marks
always so good on this show right like
he always has such clever ideas and
writes characters I'm like maybe he can
come up with a cure but no it's just
good for fantasy [ __ ] man you want
to know like some Star Trek or baby star
G [ __ ] talk to mark you looking for like
a way out of this hell that we're all in
right now he ain't the guy no I mean
it's that would be a very presidential
pose look I know things about one thing
so now I know things about all things
that's true not true I just I laid that
title on you I'm like he's so smart he
must know everything yeah I know what
we're doing CBC's up to me are you still
doing the burger Challenger the Kidder
you done burger challenge is over now
we're doing the the mother clucker
challenge which is chicken sandwiches
it's just dirty enough that's a Kevin
Smith kind of joke it just comes to the
line and make your mother go Kevin yes
good and so like my 15 year old son is
tickled at being able to say that around
the house with its mother clucker
challenge time mom look just like mark
why any other names you went with that
what about the foul challenge or must it
be odd for the record
mother Cluckers fantastic
you know I feel pretty good about that
you should you're being super dad that's
cool man that's kind of [ __ ] kid one day
is gonna be like when I was a kid like
probably at your funeral
we keep doin these challenges could be
like a month all these burgers but he's
gonna be like I remember me and dad like
did like the bird we hit the whole world
shut down I didn't know what the future
was gonna be but mall man like made me
burgers and was a funnest thing on earth
and [ __ ] like that's kind of [ __ ] kids
remember man I hope so and not the other
vast and numerous ways I've scarred in
yeah he failed in all other ways but my
god he was great at that Burger Chef he
was great in a food crisis until I knew
a lot about Star Trek and B star G yes a
lot about like making fire or
electricity or plumbing the practical
[ __ ] change of time I did a seven eight
ball I was trying to do a 72 hour fast
and then it turned into a 90 hour fast
which I broke at 10 o'clock this morning
with a B on burger and stuff and I feel
amazing
yeah everybody on the internet diagnosed
me because everyone's a doctor
apparently and told me what I was doing
wrong thankfully a few actual doctors
jumped up to be like of like if you can
fast for 72 hours the wonders it does
for your body a lot of people like it
just dude your muscles it does not eat
your muscles whatsoever it actually
releases stem cells hmm by our 72 of
fasting the body releases stem cells the
stem cells that you know go to where
they're needed most so of like in my
case I'm an ant with some heart damage
and stuff apparently those stem cells
are going there and it's crazy the
amount of good things that come out of
simply staying away from food with the
logic being this simple our ancestors or
you know everyone we came from they did
not enjoy the luxury of three meals a
day there were no mother clucker
challenges for those mother clock it was
I got a hunt this bird or like you know
I ate on Tuesday and I think we'll eat
again on Saturday like people didn't eat
not even three meals a day but like
every day and stuff so the body over
evolution has figured out ways to like
keep itself alive and what happens in
that 72 hours of fasting
is astounding the amount of things that
get healed I feel like incredibly crisp
and [ __ ] like that it's the opposite
everyone's like aren't you gonna feel
weak and stuff like that no it's it's
you feel really good JC did it once but
he did like double that time and stuff
I'm not you can't do it all the time
maybe once a month but I for me and I'm
not recommended for everybody except but
for me it it was wonderful man so that
was my week with intermittent fasting
right that's the phrase they call it
intermittent fasting but I went 90 hours
with no food just water that was it but
at the last minute I was like wait a
second I take heart pills does that
break in the fast like technically have
I broken the fast every time I take my
pills thankfully a bunch of people on
the internet we're like you're a [ __ ]
idiot no it doesn't break the fast like
and then like Jimmy Paul me Adi was like
what on Twitter why don't you ask your
doctor bro whoa Jimmy geez all right
speaking of comics man yes in the middle
of this pandemic this quarantine that
we're all in one of the biggest shocks
to our pop culture system was hearing
that diamond was stopping distribution
it's akin to you know hearing that the
Waffle House is closing how the they
used the Waffle House as a disaster
indicator on whether or not it's open or
not to decide how bad a hurricane has
been or something like that to say that
like the day the comics stopped is
probably you know for those of us in the
field of comics one of the weirdest and
and worst and most unpleasant days
filled with uncertainty if you're a fan
filled with real uncertainty if you're a
retailer which I am from time to time
because can't sell comics without comics
coming in comics come from one place
kids not Santa it's not the Easter Bunny
but it's a man who's just as wonderful
as both of those fictional characters
the guy who has created and has been
running for years diamond distribution
the people who get the comic books into
your stores man the specialty items that
only they carry the Jay and Silent Bob
figures from Jay and Silent Bob reboot
those are diamonds select figures and
stuff diamond is the lifeblood of the
comic book store industry without them
we don't have
product to sell so tonight Steve jeppie
who created diamond runs diamond is the
diamond the master of diamonds the King
of Diamonds if you will and also has
used to I mean he probably still does
like the biggest Carl Barks
collection there were a lot of Carl
Barks paintings enough he was nice
enough to be on our comic book men show
years ago he's here tonight to talk
about like the good news man when comics
are coming back and give us an insight
into what's been going on do we got
Steve I feel like it's the it's the NASA
like they're in signal silence waiting
for react juez ition of signal totally
standby kids Apollo 11 do you do you
copy Apollo 11 this is Houston do you
copy
houston we have did they even say
houston we have a problem in that movie
they did did they say houston we have a
problem where did they say we have a
problem - there's a houston we have a
problem here tech guys have left us b
we're trying to get Steve on technical
we were experiencing technical
difficulties we are please and I do
think that like your analogy of diamond
to Waffle House is super close it would
be if Waffle House were the only people
that gave you waffles that's true well
how many other waffle restaurants are
there well Denny's will give you waffles
I hop will give you whiles do you go to
Denny's with waffles in mind I mean I
know when you think waffle you think of
one place but yeah it's very true so
even I don't think we have him in Jersey
they got me I never got as far north as
the mason-dixon line
I think the furthest know what that what
it was like doing out here nope so where
do we get our waffles huh that's a
problem oh thank you Andrew and then
there's that restaurant squawking man
waffle thing remember tape heads it was
Tim Robbins and John Cusack and they got
hired to do a commercial for a rock
rhaskos bone delicious food we got food
for your attitude brakes they don't test
hello oh can you see a Steve you know I
see you perfectly beautiful ladies and
gentlemen welcome to Batman Beyond we're
honored to have a man without whom we
don't get to enjoy comic books big kid
himself who turned his passion into his
work man and we all benefit from it the
head of Diamond Steve jeppy how are you
Steve
I'm good Kevin good to see you guys
pleasure to be on the show
mark how you doing I'm doing really well
man thank you for asking
Aloha and thank you for staying up late
where are you are you in Maryland I'm in
Maryland so what is it about 10:30 here
I guess something I guess what's its
7:30 I guess yeah who sleeps anymore by
the way
the odds on that I mean we're all packed
in at home but I think I've been on the
phone 95% of the time trying to
resurrect the comic industry and I got
great news tonight it's being
resurrected tell us about well first
before you tell us the good news take us
to the dark day when you realize you're
gonna have to do something that you
never thought in a million years you
would ever have to do when did you know
that you were like look we got to stop
for a minute we got a pause like the
rest of the world well the funny thing
happened to be on the way the Waffle
House basically I remember you know
hearing all about this virus and you
know we were like any other medical
thing you hear you don't get all excited
about it but then it started to become
serious and before I knew it I'm
thinking to myself I was eight nine year
old kid reading comic books what I ever
dreamed there would come a day would I
be the guy shut the industry down not
something on my resume that I'm happy
about but I have to say that it was not
only the right decision but it was well
supportive because I think it wasn't
fair to a lot of the retailer's who
couldn't open and it's still a certain
degree of that going on now but we
targeted a date and I don't know if by
osmosis we happen to pick the right date
but now the date we picked is looking
really good for having comics back in
the store May 20th
and it's gonna be a slow crawl coming
back out we don't want to choke all the
retailers with a bombardment of product
that they can't absorb all at once
because you're gonna have to see how
many other customers come back but it's
it's it's exciting and anytime there's a
pandemic or anything of a worldwide
scale that everybody's affected equally
basically I look at it as an opportunity
I mean I'm not happy about it I don't
you know I'm sad about the deaths but
our industry so resilient you know we've
been through so many things think about
comic books they started in the 1930s
with a big crazy enough to open a
business muscle own comic books in the
middle of the Depression and yet here we
are today I mentioned the other night I
was on Dan Shane and Shane showing
Lehman Brothers Bear Stearns while all
these big billionaire companies are gone
and a little comic book stores
flourishing still around so we have a
whole sabbatical here for a couple
months kind of God's Way of giving us a
time out but we're ready to rock and
roll now and I'm excited and I think
everybody should be excited because the
reality is about to happen super excited
on this but you mentioned comics did
come about during the Depression it
sounds like we're about to enter another
depression but in the begin the first
depression comics were you know very
inexpensive a kid could buy them and
stuff do you think with the economy
where it is now what are what's life at
a comic book store gonna be like do you
think what's your feeling well I don't
have a crystal ball but history has a
way of repeating itself and through all
the years where we thought oh my god I
remember when we first became exclusive
back in 1995 the industry right around
that time half-sized
and same questions were brought up
different reasons but are we going to
survive but the tenacity of the
retailers we have some really
hardworking entrepreneurs these guys
find a way to make it happen they all
invent something they'll do something
and the good news is they have that
rapport you don't remember the number
one thing about a comic book store as
you well know it Jay and Silent Bob
store it's it's the clubhouse people
want it go it isn't just the product
that they're excited about they want to
go talk to the Clarks they want to go
talk to the owner they want to talk to
her fellow retailers when I opened my
store I couldn't believe it every comic
customer that came in back in the 70s
thought they were the only comic
customer in the world and yet you
that was what they wanted they wanted to
talk about no fun sit in the corner when
your Paula comic books I can't share it
and that interactions what's really made
it happy so these people like everybody
else are pent up right now they they're
busting out they can't wait to bust out
of their house and run to their comic
store and I think you're gonna see a
bigger come back then then people really
expect we're all planning conservatively
but I think my prediction is it's going
to be much more robust than we planned
for and it's always best to understand
over-deliver you have been in the
business for a long time what were the
other big moments you mentioned one
before but what are the other moments
where people you thought like this is it
for the industry or people said that
what were the other moments that we have
survived 1995 I think comes to mind for
everybody when Marvel bought heroes
world and the total disruption that that
called
nobody knew what was going to happen
that was obviously a big moment I
remember I forget what year it was when
ups went on strike and I remember we had
to capitulate I was very proud of my
company we've managed to still get the
books on Comic Book Day with relays we
had a network of trucks all over the
place to duplicate what we could have
sustained that forever but for the
period that we needed to we did it 2008
who wasn't affected by 2008 with the
banking industry crashing and all of
that but you know there's always been a
saying in entertainment that when times
are tough people turn to cheap
entertainment now I know it's hard to
call it cheap anymore because the price
of comics is not exactly cheap but one
common denominator that everybody has
this time they'll all get 168 hours a
week whether you're Bill Gates whether
you're Warren Buffett doesn't matter we
all get the same amount of time but we
all have a certain percentage of that
time that we feel is ours we want to do
something that we want to do we like to
do and that's where the disposable
income migrates it goes right to that
place that you love and unfortunately
for us pop culture is a wheelhouse for
that people like to read they like to
watch movies they listen to music they
do all these things because they want to
and that's a great thing to have in your
customers they want to come to know we
do respect the dentist a lot a lot of
people want to go to the dentist because
it's not a pleasant experience for the
most part but when your comic books are
in you're excited you can't wait to go
or your games or whatever it's
I think that's something we have going
on we have a pent-up demand that is
ready to explode when the stores open
back up is there something that you feel
like you learned during this pandemic
about the industry about the business
that you didn't know before like lots of
times you look at disasters as a
teachable moment so what did what did
you take away from this that that will
help you run diamond going forward I
would I would look at this as a
situation that has probably occurred
before not quite on this scale but it's
when if you were we were all being
invaded by some alien planet around you
know from another word that was
threatening the earth all sudden all
these countries would have a common
denominator they'd say wait a mo must
put aside our differences and must
figure out how we defend the earth we
don't have anything so the good thing
about our industry we got retailers we
got publishers that artists we got
writers we've got everybody the printer
of God knows everybody's got the same
desire right now and what I've learned
and it's very reassuring is that the
type of people that we're dealing with
in this industry they're all people who
want the system to work despite their
differences they're all pitching in
they're raising money to help retailers
out there finding ways to take the
negative and turn it into a positive
maybe it's a time for artists to catch
up on their schedules because this is
you know what drive cuts fell so for me
mark I think that the real blessing out
of this is always remember the things
you had that we're going well and not
take them for granted and I'm not going
to just talking about comic books I'm
just talking about the ability to walk
down the street and go enjoy yourself
walk your dog and all of a sudden you
never dreamed there will come a time in
your life where you'd actually look at
that as whoa my god I can't do that and
the kind of dodging of the people in
other countries who have that problem
regularly so it gave me a new
appreciation as running diamond it made
me feel like well I need to inject
myself back in there more I need to get
out there and use whatever influence
that may or may not have from the
experience I have to ignite some passion
and to read men I should say cuz there's
a lot of new retailers who have been
buying from diamond for 10-15 years and
I don't even know I exist because I
wasn't is visible anymore so I really
appreciate the opportunity you guys are
giving me tonight
say thank you to all the guys in the
industry and to tell them that from
where I sit and I'm in a pretty unique
seat the road looks really good ahead I
think it's not just a Pollyanna
statement all the evidences are there a
lot of things are still working that we
depend on and I think we're going to
kick ass I love that positivity we've
got a lot of retailers who watch the
show and what not what kind of support
can they expect once the doors open
because it's probably gonna be cash poor
for a little while all right what are
you doing to work with the retailers
well what we're doing is we're first of
all we're spoon feeding them a little
bit with the cooperation the publishers
we're not going to say guys you ordered
these books you got to take them and try
to put a square peg in a round hole
we know that won't work we're working
with the publishers to adjust their
orders down to levels that are maybe
more reflective of reality now that's
when they order them two months ago they
didn't anticipate a pandemic a lot of
the publishers are figuring out the ways
to make things returnable we're talking
about doing some fundraiser
opportunities to raise money for comic
stores and putting out some challenges
so that people will donate art or
whatever they got and throw it out at
you guys - we'll try to figure a way
that everybody can cooperate raise some
money we want to be patient we've always
been sorted but the de facto bank of the
industry because we realized a lot of
mom-and-pop stores don't have
capitalization and while we didn't go
into business to be a bank we go into it
with the ideas we need to be supportive
so if a guy can't pay his bill that week
for whatever reason and he's been a good
account and he's got some legitimate
problems he's not just trying to stiff
us we work with him we're gonna continue
to do that we're blessed to have a good
banking relationship that allow us to do
that so these are just a few of the
things that the retailers need I should
say we're gonna go what they need first
and I believe that a lot of the
retailer's who have already started
doing some of the stuff people want to
not new books not shipping resurrection
of the back issue market so they're
saying well you know what do I already
have in my store right now I don't have
new comics come in but what can I sell
now that I already paid for and it's
working I've had a fill boil down a
Coliseum of comics in Florida just only
this Friday he's opening eight of his
nine stores in Florida I'm so excited to
hear that it was the kind of news you
want to hear that there's some and keep
in mind we're always gonna have a
hanging over our head about a virus on
some level but at the end of the day
we're all
conscious to the fact that life has some
risks it's just about how much can you
mitigate no nobody wants to run out
there and be blatantly you know they uh
unsafe but right now I think we start to
hear a lot of good news about opening
people are doing gradually slow but sure
I think the comic industry is gonna be
as good a position as anybody else's you
imagine if people haven't had a haircut
where the women who haven't had their
nails done or whatever the salons are
gonna be mobbed they're gonna be
crucified the day it opens and but
that's the line it'll back up now we
have our version of that is if we got a
ton of product we can't go and shove it
down their throat I'm gonna take our
time we're gonna do it in partnership
the best decisions are made when you
include everybody in the food chain to
see how it affects them so for retailer
gets his opinion of this and publisher
that the distributor it is the printer
all that stuff is part of what we're
trying to do we're not gonna do anything
perfect but we feel like we've got a
good start and when is it when is a 1/2
the books hit the first in-store date
for art for diamondback wood it will be
May 20th the books should be in the
stores on May 20 that means we'll be
bringing employees back prior to that
very soon so they can prep and get ready
for the shipments that we've got certain
books already on the floor because when
this happened the April 1st shipping
group was already in the warehouse and
the April 8th should be group was in the
printer and we've since put out these of
FOC orders they call them in the retail
food retailers in a final order a cutoff
date and they can go and adjust if they
ordered 500 or something and now is oh
my god I only do 100 those orders were
canceled and now now being allowed to be
retreated you know with the current
mentality so God willing you know
unforeseen occurrence I am of the belief
that we're gonna have comics in the
stores on May 20th and the when DC when
they announced today we're gonna take
books out was that good or bad actually
as of what's today Thursday Tuesday DC
was able to put out five titles through
two of their new distributors that are a
mail order dealers actually and they're
kind of spoon-feeding to industry so
we're when our books come out
all the books that DC wise that will
have come out from that date until we're
will be concurrent with that well we may
have to stagger it a little because they
don't want them all at once but if at
some point very soon whatever's out
there will be as current with diamond
accounts as others those are the two
distributors does how what's your
perspective on suddenly two sort of
competitors entering the entering the
arena that hadn't been on the map before
to help answer a need that the industry
had felt is that do you see it as an
ongoing scenario the diamond has to
reckon with which is now competition
which in this arena you never really had
to in a long time at any rate we lost
him mark what did you do is he driving
through a tunnel yeah he's frozen he was
frozen on our side oh my god like this
good talk like this is real like deep
cuts dirty comic culture stuff but like
but like may 20th is encouraging I think
you know for that for that industry to
be able to kind of get back on his feet
and of course it will change and will
alter depending on the state but the
stores in what kind of you know
stay-at-home orders have been lifted or
or what have you been really nice to
hear to that they're not gonna be like
you got to take you know all the books
you ordered like it's smart play man
then it sounds like they're working with
that one
yeah and we're getting them back yeah
we're now con hello I'm back oh sorry we
lost you so the those two cats well who
are they the two outfits you were asking
me yeah where's me about competition and
how I feel about that well they I mean
especially like aren't these guys
technically customers like don't they
but very big and very good customers of
ours of Midtown comics and dcbs are very
very good customers of ours so we're
supplying them pretty much everything
else and they're now able to buy direct
from DC kind of a house account if you
will and I've never been afraid of
petition here the funny part with us
being this so-called 800-pound gorilla
and the Rena
people forget that we're a very small
fish in other ponds we sell toys we sell
all kinds of other things that were
regularly competing on and so it's not a
new concept to us and keep in mind going
back to when we became exclusive there
once it when I first became a
distributor were twenty distributors so
now you know and we did pretty good I
think after the the competition so I
welcome competition especially if it
grows the market if I'd rather have a
smaller percentage of the market in a
bigger market than all of a small market
so they're good people I trust them I
think that they're going to do the best
they can
I trust EC and all our other partners it
doesn't matter whether you're Marvel or
DC or a dark horse or image or I need a
dynamite boom you know Archie comics all
these people are part of the big pie
that makes up what a comic store needs
no company no man no retailer no
distributor is an island you need each
other that's that's the beauty of our
industry because when times get tough
they've found a way despite their
competition to work together and I see
that happening right before my eyes and
I'm in a good position to watch it
because we interact with everybody you
you are the conduit for most of our
dreams and you dream of doing something
and brought your dream to reality and
then the rest of us get to walk into a
specialty store and get the comics we
want and stuff like that you've you
facilitate a lot of goodwill for those
of us who love this medium so on behalf
of everybody watching I thank you but I
just wanted to ask you've been in the
business for so long
what is your single favorite moment in
your entire career children aside
professionally speaking well in comics
was my favorite moment I think that when
I it really goes back to the very
beginning of when I wasn't even in
business my favorite moment I was on
vacation I was a mailman at the time
with a wife and two kids and I was at
Wildwood New Jersey on vacation and I'll
never forget my nephew was now worked
for me for over 30 some years almost 40
years now believe it or not he was
reading a Batman comic and I was on the
beach and I was looking over his
shoulder and I start getting this
nostalgic Twitter's about come yeah I
remember all those comics and the
excitement I had when I see those little
coming attractions coming next month or
and it was like a resurrection of a part
of my life that I how do you forget
about something maybe a good example
has that I think happens to a lot of
people when I opened my comic book store
back in 1980 at Harborplace which is the
festival marketplace in Baltimore I
would be behind a counter and a guy
would come up maybe in his 50s and he
kind of this little nostalgic look on
his face and I'm remembering me in
Wildwood and I'd look at him and say
says you remember all those don't you
this yeah a little nostalgic I said so
let me ask you a question he says what
services when did you stop and join them
let me get this lost look on his face as
you didn't did you you just kind of grew
out of them but you don't really stop
them do it's okay it's okay to get back
in it's fine
and that's kind of way I felt you know
how did I stop plucking comics when I
was a kid out of quit school when I was
13 to go to work to support my mom so to
go to high school so all of a sudden you
know my comments got taken away from me
and I don't have any of my comics I had
as a kid but I've certainly made up for
it since but by and large when I got big
in the thrill of that and I think a lot
of people relate to that it's like
taking a quadrant of your brain and
reopening it kind of like when you put a
search word into your computer somewhere
that big dumb machine is a explosion of
information you just can't physically
see it but when you hit that search word
voila everything comes out that's what
happened to my brain all of a sudden
aren't she Batman Superman all these
characters were flooding at me that was
my favorite moment hands down I hope you
relate to it that I can absolutely
relate to I think you've described a
feeling a lot of people who fall out of
it and come back to it have I bet you
there aren't as many people fall out of
it anymore because lord knows those
Marvel movies the DC movies they
certainly keep him out there in the pop
culture but I know that feeling I was a
guy who was out of it at one point like
I stopped reading in high school and
then when I started hanging out with
Walter Flanagan who runs Jane ssambap
secret stash he got me back into reading
him he was older than me cooler than me
and he was reading Dark Knight Returns
and I was like we're allowed to read
comics and he was like [ __ ] anyone who
doesn't read comics and he would say
like you know people think I'm stupid
for reading [ __ ] comics I think
they're stupid
they never read Watchmen there they're
losing out not me so I know that feeling
man I was one of those cats I remember
there was no place to buy back issues
right that was a really started comic
stores there was a place to go to but
last month was hard to find I mean if
you they took the new ones off but the
other ones up there on one time I found
this little store on Caroline Street and
it was super boy earth it was number 69
whereas the balloons he's learning how
to fly and it was all beat to hell
and I bought it I was like this was the
greatest thing I just thought I found a
comic there was a hundred years old so
years later I'm in the comic industry
and I get another copy and I look at the
year and it was a year old when I got it
and at the time I thought it was ain't
you well that's probably what a kid
feels like when he finds last year's
comic because that's one he hasn't seen
and as a result this is the score and
that was a score for me man only to find
out years later to think was about what
now would be considered selling to us
because we were used to last month's
than last year's in the last 20 years
calm experience so to speak recent but
there but in the business side of this
if you would ask me what's my favorite
time I think it was probably when I got
the crystal ball the light bulb I should
say went off that I was really going to
be distributed because I think that
kicking and screaming I had Japanese
comic world I was perfectly content to
be a retailer I love retailing I love
interacting with people but I was doing
a favor for some other stores that were
opening up around the city hey Steve you
know we can't meet the minimums could
you you know let me stag my owner sure
no big deal that's for a while like six
little accounts and a pain in the ass I
didn't really want to do it but my
distributor moved to Florida got an
ability to dropship next to get over sub
distributing and then he had trouble for
no one else from when I was the kind of
person that if I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do it and that's when I finally realized
this was no longer a favor this was a
real job so I said to myself you know
Steve you're one of twenty distributors
you got about a 4% market share but you
know what there's 96% to go after I was
all excited and if I had ten air was
still 90 and lo and behold I never
dreamed it we get to the percentage it
is so what happens when you get a big
chunk of it you focus on making the
market bigger and that's what I see
right now this is like a set back a
little bit because of the VARs
going forward I see we're going to be
reinvigorated and we're going to be
faster rising from this you know this
pandemic then pretty much most other
companies and other industries I should
say because we have a product that they
want to buy they're not forced to do it
it isn't an obligation I made the
comment the other night if you own a
restaurant I feel really bad for
restaurants well these two months that
they've been closed all those people ate
somewhere else at home and so they don't
come back and say let me get all those
old meals I should have bought at your
restaurant but where's the comics they
want to go get those issues they might
have missed or in that period so we got
a lot going for us and I just can't be
more positive about I hate the fact that
people died I hate the fact that we had
this interruption but more resilient and
it's it's an American thing you know pop
comic books in a badger told I'm told
her only two real American art films
that really originated from here and if
that's true let's cling to it and
proselytize because I think that we've
got legs I love it man
you are doing the Lord's work Steve many
thanks I hope he continues to bless me
in real life I just turned 70 in January
and I feel like I'm 25 in my brain but
that's because I read comic books if
that's what 70 looks like I'll take some
seventy man you know what seventy at all
seventy but I was sick you missed your
calling mail man never mind the comic
book is I can't tell you how much I
appreciate what you're doing for the
image what you guys did with comic book
men I had to prove up to him the guys
come down that we're so cool when it
came down the smell action what people
think we're like lunatics we're smelling
comic books and they smell why I smell
wine too by the way but bottom line is
this is part of the nuance this is part
of the fun of being a collector we have
all these little idiosyncrasies and what
you guys have done to put comics in the
forefront we were the underneath um
since the 50s we were the you know the
black sheep so to speak we were two
redheaded stepchild or whatever in the
negative connotation was but now all of
a sudden it's our time
take the movies
movies the top 20 most all of them are
comic-book movies
dominating so now everybody proud used
to be a movie star much it I played
daredevil now it's here man
I played devil what do you think that
they're all cool about it it's okay and
you guys are kind of a big part of that
with this show and other things that
you've done so I just want to thank you
on behalf of the industry for what you
have done it means a great deal you have
no idea how much effect that's had thank
you for that the industry has done
everything for us for heaven's sakes we
have jobs because of comic books the
dream and I got a new buddy in Ming Chen
I mean who else is going to go to
baseball games with me baseball again
you are so incredibly sweet to tolerate
Ming as he loves you to death as we all
do man Steve Jaffe thank you for being
who you are thank you guys for keeping
the diamond fires burning and thank you
for the vote of confidence in the
industry man I feel completely relieved
ready to go Industries is been so good
to me I'd be a fool not to support it
and it's when it needs it you rock sir
hey man go to bed on the show thanks for
being here man oh my god how awesome was
that that's super cool how like again
most powerful man in comics like most
important person in comics obviously
like if if comics stop it's because of
him he had to stop because of the
outbreak and stuff but my favorite
moment was hearing the birth of what
eventually becomes diamond like him
going from like oh I don't have to be a
mailman I could be a retailer you know
being dragged into like distribution you
know and that's that's what he does it's
everything it's a secretory Channel but
oh my lord just because here iam braced
something that most people were like you
leave that behind when you grow up like
that's for kids i dude took kids stuff
turn it into a Empire man nice guy and
legit funny right you know like didn't
see that coming I didn't know you're 70
though good for him I mean I guess like
I'm almost 50 so that makes sense but
like he does look so many doesn't sound
70s but I never
sense and also no lie that guy made me
feel good about not just the future of
the comic book industry but life in
general he was very positive he's like
where is no I'm like we are are we Steve
that was awesome man that was a huge
that's cool yeah we're like a new show
man job keV I don't know we know some
people thankfully Chuck who I do all the
action figures with that diamond select
who have worked he's done our toys for
four years he was like hey man Steve
would love to come on the show I'm like
are you what like Steve Jimmy yes and it
worked I can't believe how well it
worked out himself yeah he did he looked
at me and I was like really legit
wonderful guest two minutes that's
that's a part of the comic book world we
never really get to talk about here Joe
and like hearing him like be whimsical
about it here the hearing the kid and
I'm here in the salesman in two minutes
guy who identified opportunity early on
right
all of it like just makes you realize
what makes it possible for you to walk
into a local and LCS logo column
elcbs local comic book store and like
asked for something because it all came
from that guy going alright maybe I'll
do this and he's and he was very cool
about not Santa but he rich man richest
people I've ever spoken to we spoke to
like on skype and stuff but man oh man
like comics like that's a business like
a big business yeah but it's a little
bit of him being like the president who
decides I would like to talk to CBS
today like I would like some of your air
if you don't mind even that we give you
the air to use I feel pretty good about
that that we've got dope all right now
the rest of this shows with me a [ __ ]
letdown we don't have anybody cool to
talk to after that we got yeah we'll
talk to each other we got news tell you
something about mark barnard and kids
mark barnard and is now a man of letters
an entertainer he makes funny
make-believe stories that put you to
happy places and make you want to be a
entertainer yourself before that to pay
the bills he was a news hound
he wore a press card in brim of his hat
and he went into people's faces with a
microphone looking for the facts and
stuff that instinct never dies so at
this point of the show we always turn to
mark and say mark sniff out the news and
so mark barnard has found us some news
give it up for mark barnard he's got the
news yeah it's a it's it's the the NSYNC
never dies put it atrophies a little bit
because I'm not like I'm not like
breaking news
I'm copy pasting news yeah look not
everyone like this we're a news
aggregator right look at the end of the
day we do a bunch of stories that people
put hard work on to create in other
places we just it's not we're not a news
organization we're just fans and we get
to talk although Steve geppi on the show
might have lifted us just to I think so
that might have made us legit
organization
we're like a blog that you can read
about having to read listen to and watch
reading is so like I know it's
fundamental but it's tiring so like
eriously let us do the thinking and
reading for you what what news stories
we got man well the the the latest
breaking news story I think came via
Olivia Munn I know this story you know
this story right when I saw the story
this morning I was like we're doing
Batman
beyond today I want to talk about this
story this have got big gossipy kids and
not gossipy in the way of like hey guess
what Batman might have you know zoe
kravitz in or something like that this
is like I mean I don't know it's not God
well how would you describe it it's not
maybe it's not gossiping it's not gossip
because it's first-person story yeah
it's coming from that she's legit and
she's legit it's it's very behind the
scenes he come on the scenes yes Dee is
inside baseball is this and it's also
the sort of thing that you never hear
about while a movie is both being
produced or during the standard press
rounds and actors and actresses do to
promote a movie because you got to put
new movie in the best light when you're
trying to get people to give you 12 15
bucks a clip for it yes but now that
we're kind of where were you when I was
promoting [ __ ] cop-out I could have
used that advice make sense when you say
[Laughter]
so Olivia Munn Olivia Munn was an
actress still is she was angel is very
much and also to be fair Olivia Munn was
one of us like one person with a
microphone talking on g4 that's how I
first met her and stuff every time I see
her or I interviewer on IMD Budd or
something like that I'm like I think
it's thrilling that you went from like
somebody who put mics in people's faces
to like now they put mics on you and
stuff she's cool people's good people
and a true nerd or junior like what not
even like you know nerd for money or
whatever whatever it is whatever the
gape for pave I was trying to think of
what the analogy was nerd for blurred I
don't know but she she's like in when I
was on g4 she was like dropping
knowledge like and still even to this
day she was so excited when she got cast
as Psylocke I remember that because she
like knows and loves the x-men and stuff
like that she was like imma be in one of
these movies so she got to play Psylocke
and Men apocalypse yes just the best
x-men movie ever made indeed
Andrew Dolabella but yes she she was
talking about to variety apparently the
her time on the set of x-men apocalypse
which is directed and air quotes are
undirected apparently by Bryan Singer so
she mentions sort of the the the
scattershot relationship he had with the
set of a film that he was directing do
1000 go disses dishy go ahead was she
she but she was talking about how singer
showed her how often men in Hollywood
fail upward and get away with bad
behavior she claimed it speaking to
variety that singer vanish from the set
due to an apparent thyroid issue
she had never shot a huge movie like
that she said I didn't know what was
right or wrong but I did know that it
seems strange that Bryan Singer could
check out and say he had a thyroid issue
instead of going to a doctor in Montreal
where the film was shot which is a you
know very high level working city yes
legit international capital true though
it's not you know Peoria or something
and Peoria is pretty big city - yeah he
said he had to go to LA and he was gone
for about ten days
lecture in wait what did they shut down
production more they did not he would
say he asked facetiously I know the
answer that he knows the answer they
kept making the [ __ ] movie even
though he wasn't there why because he
told them to read that part we'd be on
set I remember there's a big scene that
we'd have and we'd come back from lunch
and then one or bryony's please try to
read it as Olivia you're not doing it in
character it's very dry I feel like
there's so much drama in this you could
be put a little more into it a little
stink I don't know you've never been
working on your mom I've got six
different Munn impressions madman happy
mon rage that she worked with Bryan
Singer Mun the closest I got is a
William Munny which I feel is not the
Krait it'll work money's good now go
ahead read her quote with me on set come
back from lunch and one of Brian's
assistants would come up and show us a
cell phone with a text message on it and
he text it to the actors hey guys I'm
busy right now but just go ahead and
start filming without me and we'd be
like okay keep going I'm still just have
to pick my [ __ ] brain up off the
floor like I I'm not like I'm not saying
I can't [ __ ] leave my movies like I
wouldn't want to like you only get this
many days to make that movie for the
rest of your [ __ ] life and you don't
get to come back well they do because
they do reshoot some [ __ ] but generally
you don't get to go back man so you
don't ever want to miss a day unless
you're sick and even when you're sick
you work through it and stuff like that
this was a dude who went away because
they said he was sick but she seems to
indicate that she didn't think it was I
mean I just think that she felt that the
the behavior was unprofessional and
inexcusable and she says I'm saying even
before the me to stuff was exposed stuff
that's really horrendous and just
nauseating to be around there's also
just a bad behavior people getting away
with it and no one in the world is so
talented that it merits disrespecting
other people in their time and there are
so many talented people waiting for an
opportunity Wow that last line is a like
essentially that last line is like don't
give him a job there's like a lot of
talented people waiting
I mean there
the people who will like show up every
day that is nuts to me now this story
interests me because I I've never worked
on an x-men movie or anything like that
but I have worked up in Vancouver and
when I was working on as a actor a movie
called catch and release that Susannah
grant directed we shot up in Vancouver a
lot of our crew had worked on x-men and
xx men - the first two movies and you
know they knew I was a comic book guy
all of them were like so happy to come
over and be like you know Bryan Singer
just leaves those x-men movies and I was
like why hi I'm Kevin who are you and
they would just start telling me that
like but he would walk away and that the
second unit director would direct and
I'm like yeah but like did anybody tell
the studio and again this is hearsay I'm
like I didn't experience this but this
is from a crew member who worked on both
of the - a couple multiple crew members
who worked on both of the first two
x-men movies and apparently he could
come and go like and disappear for long
periods of time and they I don't it
seemed like they wouldn't shut things
down they would just keep going because
in you know the world of making those
big movies you got a first unit second
unit sometimes third unit so once the
money machine turns on you can't take a
break you don't get like a few days off
to go relax or something like that so it
was crazy when I first heard about it
but I only heard about it from some cats
on a crew and you know maybe they're
just dishing and maybe it wasn't that
way but when I read that story this
morning I was like oh my god this
totally corroborates like what they said
but they were talking about old movies
like x-men and x-men - yeah this
happened on like you know that movie
happened a minute ago yeah it was 2016
and I think it's it's telling that you
know Bryan Singer did almost every x-men
movie except for x3 which he didn't do
cuz he was out doing Superman Returns he
didn't do x-men first class because I
think there was a Matthew Vaughn like he
had a whole take on it or whatever but
then Bryan Singer comes back in picks
that up and does Days of Future past and
his x-men future passes good flow it's a
good flick
but it's telling that the movie that he
wanted to make the most seems to have
been dark Phoenix right like he sets it
up in x-men 2 which is the best of his
x-men movies he sets up Jean Grey and
they pay it off at x-men 3 which he was
never happy with because it was very
kind of slapdash and not quite right and
so he was building up to we're gonna
[ __ ] do Dark Phoenix we're gonna
we're gonna do the Dark Phoenix we
should have done before but not like
what who directed that was Ratner yeah
so they were like Brett Ratner's version
we're gonna do the right brainer the
right one Phoenix and he doesn't direct
that one Simon Simon Kinberg dude who
had produced you know most of not all of
them yeah and a bunch of them he stepped
in to direct it and it's like did
somebody just realize maybe he was the
apocalypse experience like if he's never
gonna be here and if the rest of us are
directing this either second unit or by
committee maybe we don't need this guy
anyway that's why again all hearsay I
don't know for a fact but from people
that have crude on those movies they
said the second aid second the second ad
second unit director took over the first
unit a lot of times when apparently
Brian would disappear if that is
allegedly if that's the case yeah which
apparently also happened on Bohemian
Rhapsody lucky he's still right that
sounds from thing to thing he gets the
Bohemian Rhapsody and again we're just
like vanish to the point where that one
story where they were like oh he's gone
and then they brought in Dexter flesh
Fletcher Fletcher I think was a second
aid to the second unit director who
stepped up and did the first unit and
then became like well [ __ ] it just let
that guy do some stuff I just like it's
you know that's I know like this is a
business of like adult children and
people aren't Fanta lies and stuff like
that but just like on a pure business
level like if you skipped like 10 days
at work don't you get fired like yeah
you know what I'm saying like and this
happened like apparently more than once
on a lot of Fox movies like who who
who's in charge by him like like you
know at a certain point don't you go
like full
we want shame on you fool me twice Simon
Kinberg you know okay I challenge you to
just not show up for to work one day and
like not have a good real reason for it
either now and then do it again and then
do it again and then see what happens I
wonder like which scenes like I I mean
this is so stupid but I wish somebody
would be like he wasn't here for this
there's this like you could look at the
movie and see I mean for years I've been
saying you know I'm always like hey man
everyone's a better filmmaker and man
[ __ ] and look Bryan Singer's a way
better filmmaker than I'll ever be but
now I wonder how much of that film he
actually makes based on that story but
yeah man that was such a weird it was so
a weird callback because we shot catch
and release in like 2004 and I remember
like like cuz you know they they were
telling me because I like comics and
also I'm a director and stuff like that
so 16 years later dude
like it's been going on for a minute Wow
I mean like to a certain degree I
appreciate and admire the grift of it
which is like oh he conned a studio into
thinking that he was a good director who
was there all the time
props where props are dude I was not
courageous enough to say it Marx
absolutely like Bryan Singer is an evil
genius apparently who figured out how to
get a studio to constantly let him do
whatever he wanted to do like how do i
fail upward I know I'll choose the right
I I know a thing or two about failing
upwards he did not fail he's just kept
winning and winning and what wow man so
there it is it should give people hope
at home cuz that means like maybe I can
direct an x-men movie one day because
maybe Bryan Singer will go home for 10
days and I'll be on set in the milieu
you're gonna direct the x-men movie me
basically it's like being at that
drugstore when like Jack Warner would
come in it's like you're a movie star
today Lana Turner man episode account
walks that's how they pick directors for
the x-men movies yeah who's standing
around here zero director at the bar
because we lost stars where is he
unclear
unclear I'll tell you right now they
never called me it mustn't have been
that bad you know what I'm saying
because if they were truly in hell
they're like we'll take anybody even
[ __ ] Kevin Smith but it never did man
they were like you know what we'd rather
die with pride I wouldn't even if they
called I'd be like I can't do that I'm
not as talented as Bryan Singer or
anybody I don't have a vision for that
but anyway this is and this is not me
talking as a filmmaker I'm just being a
gossipy little hen as a film fan is me
talking as a consumer and I'm like
[ __ ] you advertised for me a
Bryan Singer film if they're not a brine
Singh is there a class-action suit and
all this where we find our Bryan Singer
edge where we find a way to bring the
studio to bear I claim fraud for 20th
Century Fox restitution is give me an
x-men movie I mean right now I'm sure
like all those people are like hey man
I'm my problem Disney from yeah good
luck and it's also all it's almost weird
because it's like I guess it doesn't
matter because that whole universe is
closed yeah and the next time we see the
x-men it won't be the x-men that
everyone apparently got tired of
watching that last one did not I did
like Kevin Smith numbers for an x-men
movie it was a game over at that point
yet this is all like history from a
country that doesn't exist anymore yeah
exactly did you see that x-men the last
one Dark Phoenix it played on HBO
like a couple weeks ago during the
pandemic and it was trending because
people were just like are you serious
like a bunch of people finally had a
chance to watch it for free on HBO or
not for free they watched our Phoenix
when I have no place else to go
and nothing else to do and for free and
they had a lot of time oh they let the
whole world know how they felt about it
oh yeah I could never do that I mean it
wasn't my cup of tea but I could never
[ __ ] on somebody else's movie I know how
hard it is to make one of those things
and stuff so hard sometimes you need to
take ten days off if you don't show a
little production because you know
sometimes you need a little you time
wasn't today hard
you weren't here sir
but what I want to blank there are many
reasons I'd love to bring my father back
from the dead but this is one of them
just to be like do you know dad you know
what Bryan Singer did Daisy left his job
because my old man would be like if I
left the post-office pretend [ __ ]
days they would have fired me it would
be that simple
like give me some of that director work
and stuff like thank you for coming back
from the dead of the onward conversation
you have with your dad but in the ball
one minute my brother my brother's
trying to see what's going on he's like
what you asked him I was like talk to
him about the Bryan Singer tobacco and
he's like you're an idiot oh my god well
I don't know who's nice to see him he
had opinions alright enough of talking
about where where's Bryan Singer these
days wasn't he supposed to be on a
trenchcoat isn't he it was he's not
doing Red Sonja anymore
no millennium backed away from him and I
think there's still Red Sonja but not
with him so weird cuz isn't he the
director of record for Bohemian Rhapsody
and it made like a zillion dollars
rami malek won an Oscar did not think
Brett Ratner from the stage not Brett
Ratner up Brett sorry Bryan Singer he
didn't he didn't like just everybody
like that is Olivia Munn level shade
thrown rushing and it won like two or
three Oscars it won like sound mixing it
won something something else
nobody thanked that dude for anything
really yeah I believe he's a Jersey boy
I mean there's one in every barrel
rotten apple yeah in Jersey I thought
you got an apple no you realize one of
those [ __ ] Jersey Boys everything
maybe this barrel but my barrel is fine
I think he I think he if I remember
correctly I think he's from Jersey
alright enough about yeah that but that
is legit story for our world right it is
totally interesting interesting shady
but like not not mean shady yeah and not
unfounded shady and also like you know
I used to be that brave brave is Olivia
Munn where I'd be like oh you know who
is an [ __ ] and I'd [ __ ] tell you
in [ __ ] like that and then you get older
and you're like maybe everyone doesn't
know need to know every [ __ ] thing I
think and stuff
so I'm not courageous enough really I
mean the last time I was honest like
where I'm like you know what it was on
cop-out and stuff but honestly nothing
bad has happened since that's probably
why but the fact that she's given an
interview where you know and she was
doing it while raising up another
director she we had worked with Justine
Bateman mmm Jason Bateman sister who
played Mallory on family ties and she
was saying she was such a great director
and she goes you know conversely I was
on this so she didn't just go out you
know look in a [ __ ] or shade on the guy
it was in conference we were in
conversation about another director and
stuff but anyway we spent enough time on
it we did there was a there was a bit of
a fracas between Universal and AMC and
regal yeah over who's gonna practice
this this is [ __ ] nuclear war it's
nuclear war but it seems like it might
just kind of boil down to a bit like a
shooting skirmish on a border no but
he's at the beginning in the end the
trolls was trolls world tour was
released by Universal on video on demand
given that they couldn't put into
theaters they have this movie lying
around and kids are cooped up sick [ __ ]
it we'll just do it video on demand
first and they made a hundred million
dollars did very well wait I mean we
don't know how much the movie cost no
and they did spend a lot of money
marketing there were billboards
everywhere before the pandemic and stuff
but 100 million dollars on VOD in a week
or two weeks or whatever they've done it
is undeniably great and it's a scary
thing for the movie theaters this is
their greatest fear remember a few years
back when Universal dip their toe in
this water in the Washington I think
Seattle market with that Eddie Murphy
heist movie the Brett Ratner movie and
they were like you know we're gonna try
like in this town like it was two weeks
after its debut we're gonna try
releasing the movie you could watch it
in your house for 30 bucks and it was a
small market drought and you know the
theaters the the
zippers went crazy and we're like if you
do this we're throwing you out because
they realize that like they know if you
start letting people watch big movies at
home it's all over the theatrical
experience is gone they won't need a
movie theater as much and so this
pandemic is terrifying the [ __ ] out of
them in the midst of this Universal
takes trolls out and does 100 million
bucks and then on the heels of it they
just announced two days ago they're
going to go straight to video release or
digital release bypassing theatrical the
same way like trolls did with Judd
Apatow movie starring Pete Holmes Pete
Holmes
the king of Staten you know Pete Pete
Holmes so but still Pete Holmes is in a
Judd Apatow thing I could see the vendor
the Pete's there's not a ton of Pete
Pete Davidson is in this movie Kingston
island which is gonna be a big summer
comedy and stuff Judd Apatow directed
and Universal just announced we're
releasing that straight to digital
release as well they were so encouraged
by the results with the trolls tour
it's it's a of course a great move for
them to release king of Staten Island
home release because think about let's
say we opened up next month and they're
like yeah you won't come see the king of
Staten Island people probably aren't
gonna rush the movie thing you know how
much like [ __ ] money they're gonna
have to market to spend to get people to
come out and see that movie so right now
you just put it on digital and they'll
probably make a lot more money than they
would have done going theatrical right
and this summer you're never gonna feel
a movie house like I'm just not gonna
even for a movie that everybody wants to
see desperately you're only gonna be
half speed and half capacity and most of
these movie has is to keep the social
distancing in line so yeah it was it's
not gonna make the money needed to make
going theatrical that's just not
possible and I think that when Universal
said not only we're doing it with king
of Staten Island but we are going to
case-by-case examine what makes sense
for us in terms of theatrical versus VOD
versus a smaller window even to do the
both AMC lost their minds and she was
like we will
never show another Universal movie in
AMC Theaters regal cinnamon was like
yeah [ __ ] yeah we won't either wait
regal join this yeah so last I checked
in on the story AMC was like we're not
gonna play in universal movies anymore
now another chain is jumpin that this is
what they've done before in the past
they the exhibitors theater change
circle the wagons and they're like no
this is where we drawn the line on the
sin and if you're going to do this then
you're out of our theaters and that
gives the studio's real pause because as
much as like old man I could make a
sweet hundred million off a drop in this
for digital release what happens when
they want to release a movie they need
2500 screens to open on so that they can
earn their money back as a big
blockbuster film and stuff and you can't
throw your movie up on fifty percent of
those screens because you made the mad
back in the day so how do you think
blinks here's here's the wrinkle to add
to this this past year I think the end
of 2019 beginning of 2020 I think is the
FCC US control over this has decided to
ease back on what was called the
Paramount rules that had been set in
place in like the 1940s which prohibited
theater chains from being owned by
studios themselves used to be Paramount
owned its own chain and put all the
Paramount movies in it and United
Artists and so forth and so on and they
realized that that was that was choking
the business so they made it illegal I
mean in an antitrust ruling that that
massive studios could not also own their
own distribution because that means
you're making it and you're showing it
so right you've gotta be exclusionary or
giving priority to your own movies to
the exclusion of your competitors movies
which doesn't give you an even playing
field those restrictions are being eased
and we're in a place now where some of
these chains are declaring bankruptcy
you know AMC is like on the edge of it
I think Cinemark did I think there's one
other chain that is and so if Universal
is gonna be like I'm sorry famous he's
like we won't show your movie universe
are gonna say fine we're gonna buy your
own [ __ ] chain and Shore movies
ourselves and you know what we have
coming up next year we have Fast and the
Furious number nine which was going to
make two billion dollars of the box
office now do you not want that AMC or
do we get to keep all that money
ourselves what a Dame's they say AMC is
still developing its it's a little bit
like both parties are beginning to
retreat from what had been from the from
DEFCON one yeah from from the the cinema
nuclear Armageddon that was that they
were facing and Universal said well it's
a case-by-case thing and we'll adjust as
we see fit but we want to be you know
careful to make sure that our
distribution partners are not left out
in a and she was like well you know
maybe it's not we won't show any
universal movies but maybe again it's a
it's a lot of like there had been
posturing and then reality sunk in and
everybody's gonna go back to their
corners and you're gonna see fast and
furious in your AMC a list next summer
because all comes down to like money and
then I'm gonna leave money on the table
nobody liked you know what [ __ ] ego this
is all about money and now more than
ever they're gonna have to like team up
like cuz it's not gonna be what it was
before things ended then just for a long
time till there's a vaccine you ain't
gonna see no packed movie house yeah at
least not in any responsible state so
you know those pills still have social
distancing and full effect
so yeah they better come to terms as
smart no point in fighting right now
fight the virus don't [ __ ] fight the
theaters yeah and so like and I do think
that you know Disney has also come close
I mean onward went like a couple of
weeks after theatrical straight to
Disney Plus not even VOD just no they
did go VOD I bought it first and then
like a weeks later Leslie Plus and so
like you know nobody was really pissed
off at Disney for doing that but they're
pissed over Universal we're doing this
cuz nobody wants to get mad at Disney
well I don't they want to get mad at
Disney cuz it's Disney like just cuz aw
Mickey Mouse or it's like they own
everything because like no theater chain
in their right mind it's never going to
say we won't show any Disney makes its
own rules for so many things well
hopefully those cats will you know play
nice and [ __ ] yeah
when Titans rumbled let them fight
speaking of thank you for keeping it on
brand that was amazing
Disney is is producing a live-action
Hercule
these remake which to me is only notable
here there was a cartoon Hercules there
and they're remaking their cartoon
they're remaking their cartoon is Danny
DeVito coming back unclear there's been
no casting word the Russo brothers are
producing it oh yeah those guys look
I'll see anything they do they made the
greatest [ __ ] movies of all time we
just passed a very important anniversary
Avengers endgame the one-year mark we
did everybody celebrating the movie
coming back and everybody at home so
we're all talking about our favorite
moments and [ __ ] and it just you get to
relive it Russo brothers did like a live
tweet yeah we Markus and McFeely also
the marques McFeely did yeah and they
like put up clips of them like the
moments in the movie theater with the
crowd going at [ __ ] like they shot their
movie - it was cool it's very [ __ ]
cool and they also put up if they didn't
put they showed still as I think from a
sequence in which Stephen strange was
wearing the Iron Man armor and Tony
Stark was wearing dr. Strange's we saw
that we saw that when they showed us
that picture and came over to ask we
were like what and they were like you
can't tell Amy Baum yeah we won't not
furn until we're on a podcast until
after you do it they did share it though
fine yeah they did
yeah we got to see that a while ago I
was super dude yeah man it was hey so
here's something that happened this week
I put up a tweet and I've I'm a
heartbroken
my my take on the Avengers endgame
moment when Captain Marvel gets punched
out by fan OHS and music gets dire
because she was gonna save the day
and Tony is shocked and then and he
looks at Doctor Strange and Doctor
Strange you know the shaky hand holds up
the one like indicating well what did it
indicate of course we all knew he was
indicating let he saw every future when
he cocked his head a lot and there was
one future one reality in which they
beat Thanos so my take on that moment
and I put it up
Twitter would be like a man does anybody
have a different take because I've saw a
few people have a different take on my
take on that moment is it's very dire
the music is dire the moments dire and
all the expressions and looks between
characters are very dire what my read
was is Tony Stark sees captain Captain
Marvel bless you get blown away or punch
the [ __ ] out of bye-bye Thanos and he
looks to dr. strange dr. strange my take
on this this is how I saw endgame every
time I saw it and I've seen it [ __ ]
30 times when he hold up that finger my
take on it was he was telling Tony that
was the one chance like cuz he was like
you know hey man you said we'd do then
you know we win and which one is this
the one and he goes I can't tell you if
I tell you it won't happen so for him to
go like this in that moment to me played
like him going that was well that was
the one winning time line and she just
got [ __ ] toasted so now all bets are
off and that based on what I saw Tony's
reaction of shock and [ __ ] was not dr.
strange going this is the one go for it
because they never had a [ __ ]
conversation where he was like when I
point to you that means go for it you
never [ __ ] said go for it and [ __ ]
like that so I took this to mean dr.
strange being like that was it we're
[ __ ]
and Tony in desperation makes the move
that he makes like he wouldn't have
chosen to do that if all hope wasn't
lost that was my take on it so the
internet had a bunch of people going
like I don't think it's that at all that
wasn't my tag at all and so I hit up the
smartest person I knew and I said hey
man hit up Markus and McFeely would you
like I like the smartest person I knew
not for his opinion but
free so I was like ask those cats man
cuz I think I'm right
and Mark was like on it and like very
rarely relatively quickly who'd you
reach it was McFeely McFeely because
also we none of us had much to do and
also good to know in a crisis you can
count on McFeely that Marcus know he'd
calling you back apparently he's got
better things to do so McFeely gets back
to mark and tell him when he said and he
said that it's it's not that was the one
shot that's now it's gone it's this is
what I saw and I think it jives with the
idea that if I tell you what's gonna
happen
it won't happen which is if I tell you
you're going to have to kill yourself to
save humanity it's you're never gonna go
because you have every reason to stay
behind you got your kid you got your
wife you got your life you're never
gonna strike you're filling in a lot of
blanks there but keep going keep going
and so it's it's it's happened it's in
the moment it's this is this is the shot
you now have to do the thing you don't
want to do or you're going to have to do
so what do you mean the thing you don't
want to do they never had a discussion
where Ironman was like look I don't want
to [ __ ] kill thanos I don't want I
got to live through this he said that's
Captain America where's like gotta hold
on to what I haven't should but there
was no like you know [ __ ] railroad
track laid for some moment with strange
where strangers like well if I point at
him he's gonna know that even though he
don't want to be the hero he's got to be
the [ __ ] hero cuz let's go through
the questions and I know I'm wrong
because the [ __ ] writer said you know
what it was but like I I've been for the
next 20 minutes I wouldn't call it
argued but went back and forth with Mark
and text going like well I don't think
that's right and explaining why
mansplaining to mark or you know McFeely
splaining if you will to the writer that
like I I didn't I didn't it wasn't as
I'm not saying it's wrong or bad but it
wasn't as satisfying to me if dr.
strange goes like this and that is meant
to be some indicator that this is the
one chance or this is the one reality in
which we beat him number one why would
Tony move like if he's gone
this is the one there's no indicator
that that's your cue he's just saying
there's one reality in which we win and
of course he didn't tell him like and in
that reality you beat him he could have
[ __ ] said that you know what I'm
saying he didn't have to tell him he's
gonna die but he could have said in the
reality that I saw like you you win and
Tony could be like how and he could be
like well I can't tell you that but you
know it's kind of a dick move to be like
I can't even say what role you play in
this but he didn't technically say so
Tony goes hey man what is it he and be
in endgame he's like you saw all those
futures man one of which we win is this
it and Doctor Strange goes I can't tell
you if I tell you that it won't happen
and Iron Man's like me and [ __ ] you and
goes off back into the fight so that
moment where he holds up a finger to him
how did how on earth does that
communicate go for the [ __ ] glove
right now especially if you watch the
movie it's so desperate like all the
music stops because all hope is lost
because they just watched [ __ ]
Captain Marvel get his ass her ass
kicked and that was the big hope and
[ __ ] so if you're saying I still it
don't track for me that he would be like
you just saw our greatest weapon get
knocked out so we're gonna win no nobody
was looking that way and strange his
face wasn't even like you know he was
just like and granted his hand shaky
because of the operation but he had the
grave [ __ ] it did that's that was
keeping in character his you know he's
also holding back a tidal wave no I
choose to believe that that is dr.
Stephen strange hands have been mangled
in that accident that's what makes him
the sorcerer supreme he can't do his
surgery anymore so he when they show him
periodically like when they do hand
stuff with hands sounds so dirty when
they do hands to hand jobs with Benedict
Cumberbatch well the shakes make it
awesome yeah he's ready he does keep the
shake going which I always respect cuz
I'm like right on man like that was a
big part of Doctor Strange like not his
entire mythos he can't be who he wants
to be because an accident ruined his
hand so he became something else instead
and he's always reminded like cuz his
hands like [ __ ] shake and stuff so I
took it I mean don't make me put up
another tweet do you think that he was
nervous and that's why
I thought it was just dr. strange hands
I thought it was strange because he's
doing crazy magic holding back a giant
tidal wave away you guys I hear you back
there Andrew I'm not liking your version
of endgame
where [ __ ] makes sense oh my god like
what [ __ ] being nervous he's the
sorcerer supreme I'm telling you man
that's him I bet you if you ask the
Rousseau bro you know what right -
McFeely cuz he'll get back to us in live
time that past in my mind that is
Stevens hands still having the shake so
he was just holding up a one-finger to
him and it was very slow and you know
purposeful because it's a movie and [ __ ]
like that
but the shakes for me were about you
know Stevens I won't totally give you
that thank you
you can hob so he holds up one finger
with the most dire face of all time that
does not indicate this is the one in
which we win it just like scared as [ __ ]
and then they cut back to Tony and Tony
is scared of [ __ ] and the music
indicates it like after he gets up the
one it's like the music goes down on the
Tony shot because he's like that was it
we're [ __ ] so I read that as Tony's
desperation because he he was
essentially told by the one guy who was
like I know we went one of them and then
he event he finally tells him we are not
going to win this because that was the
one that was our chiller that was it and
it just [ __ ] one away and so for me
it makes Tony's sacrifice even better
because played out the way that McFeely
the way I was intended and the
filmmakers wanted most Leone it's a bump
that they want to sell you is the idea
that essentially dr. strange going like
this is the one chance go but they never
had a conversation about you go like
when I give you the indicator you will
go when I see jewelry they told led me
to a different place where I'm like
everything's [ __ ] and I like my
version better the version where they
were Iron Man himself is [ __ ]
convinced that they're gonna lose those
two dudes have a secret one dudes like I
know how this ends and the other dudes
like I know you know how it ends but
you're not gonna tell me and [ __ ] like
that
then the one dude goes and then the
other dude is just like [ __ ] were
screwed all right well I I might as well
go for it he goes for the [ __ ] death
move the last thing he could possibly
try and he gets [ __ ] kicked
mercilessly and punched by a man three
times his size now who knows if he's a
man an alien and [ __ ] and that's heroic
to me where he [ __ ] that's a the last
gambit it wasn't foretold strange didn't
see that I'd be it's disappointing to me
if strange foresaw bad like I I liked my
version where strange saw a world where
we loved reality where they won and then
it slipped through their [ __ ] fingers
and all hope was lost and they were
gonna [ __ ] lose and Tony's like this
no and sacrifices his life to do that
cuz otherwise Tony could he could have
held up the finger and Tony we've been
like oh we win this one great I'm gonna
kick back I'm sure the Hulk has this
like he's the one that got to get the
glove right not me I can't do the snap
so the best part is you still get to
have your version existed no but I wish
mine was Canada yeah it's weird man and
how many people like reacted to the
tweet not negatively just like that was
not my page yeah and they were like that
wasn't my take at all I was like oh my
god really
so I asked mark mark got me an answer
pronto and like that answer
so I argued for a while and then mark
stopped texting just ghost he's gonna
keep go was he was just like you know
what let him spin his wheels
let him read himself battle take a nap
[Music]
I'm the nerd me [ __ ] you mark barnard n'
who knew he had a line man and his line
was like Kevin I know you didn't like
the answer but you got the answer forth
back and forth back and forth and scene
so tell me how the scene plays that
scene plays Doctor Strange the vision
that he saw in his head is that Tony
Stark is going to die he knew that he
knows fair enough
and the reason you can't tell him is
because if I tell you're gonna die
you're never gonna saddle up fare so you
have to think that you are going to be
able to as you say to cap I got it I got
a
protect what's my god they're keeping my
back yes really most important is what I
have can't so he knows he would never
obviously we're not nearly as good a
writer as Markus and McFeely although I
should because we couldn't do the
dialogue properly but I will point out
that if you're putting Markus and
McFeely in an order McFeely goes above
Marcus because McFeely gets back to you
like that this is one of that this is
the one of the most powerful
screenwriters in Hollywood and he texted
Marc back in three minutes or less I
will say I don't have Marcus's digits so
it's not like it was a race to see you
responded it's I called the one dude his
number I had preferred I was making
assumptions on various information I
provided
Christopher Marquis a lovely man who did
not deign to give me as both of those
talking dudes a great I'm sure he had
his numbers he would got back to look
everyone sitting around I'm sure he
would have been like oh my god you would
he wanted something about endgame [ __ ] I
know that tell me I know all the things
so he holds up the finger like Captain
Marvel gets punched out all hope seems
lost yes Tony looks over and he's like
dude what the [ __ ]
and he's like no there's still a way to
win that's what you take that's what I
take it and this is it is that this is
the one way to victory
JC but what do you mean do it you can't
say do it like they had some previous
conversation where it was like you know
what you do when the time comes and I
give you the signal do it means go pull
the jewels out of his [ __ ] glove like
you guys talk about it like as if it
right there's no plan there's no plan
what it's but it's not but but all I
greet strange saw it but never tells
Tony what he sees right so there can't
have been a previous discussion as to
when I hold up my finger you steal the
jewels right it's more like dude is it
over and he says no this is the path to
victory and then Tony's like oh it's not
over great [ __ ] it he's got the stones I
got to go get the stones I think yeah
that sounds like it's filling in a lot
of like conversation that came from just
this him going is it over it's not over
it might be over we're on the path
nobody talked about a path he literally
went like this Tony looked desperate and
scared and then [ __ ] ran it
a nose you know when he had the [ __ ]
glove then took a beatin and [ __ ] and
then of course we all know what happens
look I respect that that is the movie
but it's wrong it's wrong no it's
beautiful I find no fault in that movie
but I I gotta be honest with you I'm you
know for years I've been leaving people
critics and not just critics with some
people online they're like you shouldn't
be a filmmaker and I was always like no
you're wrong they're probably right I
can't figure out simple [ __ ] like that
if I didn't I remember seeing Mulholland
driving at the end of the movie be like
what the [ __ ] happened and my wife had
to explain it to me and I was like oh
that was a good movie I don't think I'm
very bright at the end of the day I
really don't because it seems like
everybody read that moment correctly
except me and I loved my take on the
moment man so I don't know how to
reconcile this it's all right that's the
beauty gonna be weird next time I watch
endgame it's gonna be like being you
know into a relationship where somebody
is cheated on you and you like I
forgiving you and get back together and
then you see the [ __ ] she [ __ ] in a
restaurant and then you're like oh
remember that moment
remember that guy for a million dollars
yeah remember when you almost ruined our
relationship this is more like just how
I was wrong about that movie scene how
many other movie scenes am I wrong about
mark how do I know that Empire Strikes
Back is the movie for me that it is for
you we will discover this on may the
fourth plug plug you know we just did
butter smooth [ __ ] Segway smooth man
that's how we artfully leave that other
conversation behind smooth into this
on May 4th ladies and gentlemen may the
fourth a Disney holiday sanctioned
holiday hmm there are you know
celebrations all around the galaxy
indoors
and there's gonna be one right here man
is look around us scum and villainy
cantina [ __ ] may the fourth that's
their Christmas for heaven's sakes and
so even though human involved yes even
though it's you know like a world where
we can't come out to the bar and
we're still shut down JC and crew have
put together a wonderful thing so JC a
new camera and he can give us the lineup
look at him alone in that booth it's so
sad you look like a writer who's come to
this place he's like I just want to
finish my put this put the camera back
on I just want to finish my screenplay
so does anybody get my background a hole
like you're an idiot
a few people there were a few I don't
like that a few that means we're in the
minority
Rangers we're not getting traction as
everybody else just like [ __ ] him he's
an idiot why do we watch it was
scrolling so fast I could barely read it
I tell you man I that really made me
like come face to face with my absolute
ignorance in there I'm not a smart man I
didn't go to college I'm a man with a
high school education and I faked it
through most of life and I'm out there
giving people advice about nutrition and
health look at me what the [ __ ] is my
problem I really discovered who I was
[Laughter]
but you show up every day I do I do you
know how you play the game attendance so
anyway back to JC tell them what we're
doing okay
so we're doing a 24-hour it's a Star
Wars bar character or a drink back to
him a 24-hour live stream that starts at
midnight like Sunday going into Monday
midnight and we're gonna roll Star Wars
content for 24 hours straight right so a
big part of that is gonna be you guys
watching Empire Strikes Back the Disney
Plus version so people can watch you
watch and talk about the movie that
you've seen a couple times in your life
so sweet
we've got a fun interview with Leonard
Maltin talking about oh royalty red
they're interviewing George Lucas on the
VHS release that we all had to fast
forward through four years to get to the
actual movie so he tells the whole
backstory on how that
bend and and how it went down and that's
really fun Greg Grunberg snapped Lex Lee
from episode 7 & 9 is funny talking to
some facet maker
running so he's got he's talking to fan
film makers for about an hour 500 first
people and then actually we have cory
doctorow who is and i'm gonna screw up
his title but he is the head guy of the
the fair use foundation the electronic
fair use foundation or that's not quite
right but whatever that foundation is
talking about fair use with regards to
disney owning the hashtag made the
fourth they put out there a bit was this
right there was a story wrong moment on
if it's a story but they put up a tweet
star wars account on twitter right like
where they were like hey send us your
pictures and hashtag you know may the
fourth or whatever and we'll create a
low you know that would be surprising it
for you then there was a follow-up tweet
that was like you know put some legalese
in but it was very just sounded very
imperial this legalese cuz they're like
you know just know that any photo that
you hashtag with may the fourth is owned
by Disney you know and suddenly people
are like what the [ __ ] I'm not that's my
picture of my kid and if [ __ ] Princess
Leia costume [ __ ] you that's my picture
and it wasn't that like it wasn't them
going like remember when everyone found
out that one thing with like everything
you put on Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
Jones you don't own it anymore you like
what and then you find the real truth
and it was kind of like that to some
degree but it created a real tempest in
the teapot man
and it did if it was the intention ever
wasn't the intention it had to get
Disney paws to be like I maybe we don't
know that I think they deleted part of
that tweet also or they adjusted it or
trying to make it more clear yeah I
think that's what they dread but we're
just gonna say we own it yeah like look
we meant what we meant but it made us
look bad so we're gonna stop saying it
now
like worst Chris giving them PPP money
back they announce what they're doing
that yeah like what immediately or cuz I
heard one story they're like well we'll
pay it back eventually
I think Shake Shack did the same thing
as a small business owner man good
camera on JC as a small business owner
were you're like [ __ ] Ruth's Chris
really really really I mean shake
Shack's a publicly traded company and
they got ten million dollars you know
what we could do with ten million
dollars open a scum and villainy
[Laughter]
intently you didn't fill out the right
[ __ ] forms you didn't fill out the ten
million dollar form well I looked at the
rules which said you had to have less
than 500 employees no bring me the
standard rich and famous contract Shake
Shack has two employees per location in
the US that is some Olivia Munn level
shade right there man that was a
frustrating morning
sarcasm is stronger this one as truly
but we have Sam Witwer Kyle Newman and
Jen Murrow the voice of Darth Maul
himself and and I believe hey man did
you see speaking of Darth Maul the Clone
Wars they had Maul meet ahsoka for the
first time and they used ray Park read
part came back and did the fight and
they did the animation based on
rotoscoping or whatever the [ __ ] so I
thought that was cool as hell man and it
was really good yeah episode really good
they've really done a great job like
Dave Filoni like literally turn [ __ ]
Darth Maul into a more interesting
character than he ever was in any in you
know the one movie was in before he got
cut now all right so it sounds like may
the fourth is gonna be a fun day to hang
out on the stream is it the scum and
villainy stream where they're gonna know
all of our social channels so our
Facebook our twitch and twitter and are
you doing a benefit or anything like
that
hey party the one thing that we will do
that's really cool is if you're in Los
Angeles we're going to do curbside
pickup for scum and villainy blue milk
we're doing like a little snack pack
like a bad lunch yeah you can come and
get some boozy blue milk some chips a
scum and villainy patch glow stick and
like a fruit by the foot ooh
that do you have a price on this yet
eleven dollars and 38 cents that's
[ __ ] dope why tell my just a totally
random number they came in so wait so
they can all day long people can hang
out here on the stream 24 hours but if
you're in LA you could actually drive by
drive up 6377 Hollywood Boulevard
whatever and it's just it's like a Happy
Meal how many do you want four of them
we hand you four we'd put them in your
back seat you speed off without paying
today prepay so you know it'll be like a
McDonald's like you'll drive up swipe
your card then the next you know you
drive up they put this stuff in the car
and they go right on and you're doing it
right on all right on Hollywood right up
front we're gonna assembly-line it never
in any other world but this world could
you [ __ ] run a drive-through on
Hollywood Boulevard man is always
traffic out there but now it'll work out
nicely yeah um so they can get a big
happy meal with blue milk in it Jim how
dope man if you're in LA you got to
patronize man but if you're not in LA
and you just want to hang out with the
program and watch me and Marc do our
commentary are they watching us no
they're watching the movie or we've
idiot where I do I mean the idea see
they put you on the computer and the
movie on the TV I think so you'll see us
in the stream as well man and that is
May the 4th for you know Star Wars guys
are on it
e 7 or 8 o'clock at night or the night
show the headliners ooh I like that
all right what other news what wither
wither more news we're the mornings and
I have with him more Star Wars news to
boot is so [ __ ] fortuitous time just
talking about story Disney has decided
in their infinite wisdom to make rise of
Skywalker available on Disney Plus on
may the 4th ah well that's [ __ ] make
sense it was it was not supposed to hit
Disney Plus until July but they were
like [ __ ] they're like we gotta make
up for that tweet good we really pissed
everyone off tell them we don't own
their pictures anymore I swear to god
that's good man but I already own it
yeah digitally if you wanted to watch
the entire nine parts of this thing they
have all of them now they have all of
them all so that's the one probably the
first place in history that you can
watch the entire Skywalker song yep you
can sit down soup-to-nuts go from
beginning to end and then of course tune
in to watch us watch a movie at at 7:00
or 8:00 on Saturday but yeah you could
do that trying to wet our beaks a little
bit in that Disney plus money stream
just a little bit just a little pecker -
I just want to wet my beak a little the
the straight Disney Plus I was like what
do I want to talk about I literally
watch it every day absent me what do you
think I watch all the time the world
according to Jeff Goldblum is that a
thing
yeah that's I Simpsons well I bought
Disney Plus just to watch The Simpsons
and me and the wife had 16 seasons of
Simpsons that we hadn't seen hmm not to
mention the earlier 15 seasons that we
did see that we could re watch so we've
been doing deep dives on The Simpsons
and OH
what it's absolutely [ __ ] delightful
man and I saw the show where they went
16 by 9 where they stopped being the
standard you know square ratio although
on the Disney app it's not in its proper
aspect ratio the first seasons not a
little squared but you see the episode
where they do and it's just and
everything looks like more vibrant and
better but uh you know for years people
are showing as funny as it was I I'm
legit having a good [ __ ] time I have
not encountered a bad season yet you
know you hit an episode one or two where
maybe you don't enjoy it as much as the
others I don't dig the episodes where
they tell stories with
in a story like where there are in
medieval times and [ __ ] like that not
like I don't like him but like I'd much
prefer the stories go ahead describe it
to my wife is like she's I we were
watching an episode where like Marge is
flashing back and telling a story and so
it's set in the times of a [ __ ]
medieval times and I changed the episode
Jennifer's like what are you doing I was
like I don't like the ones that aren't
real and that's when I when I said that
out loud I should have realized then
that I probably watched end game
incorrectly all my assumptions are
really just asses of me and me all right
what else would go um good for Disney
man good for Disney I'm more Disney more
Star Wars the creator of Russian doll oh
that's Leslie head Leslie Hedlund I know
her going back to Miramax she's be she
used to be Miramax
and he's cleaning up around she you know
did what was Russian doll of course but
prior to that she's done some movies
including the about last night remake
mm-hmm years ago but a good real nice
kid she's very talented kid now no
longer kid [ __ ] pioneer another
pioneer [ __ ] a the emmy-winning
Russian doll did she win an Emmy yeah
this is the man like good kid it's like
an Emmy winner she's like [ __ ] you
silent bill I knew ya I knew her back in
the day at Miramax really nice kid nice
and I've every time I see her name pop
up in the industry I'm like god damn it
good for her man but yes she's she's
developing a female centered Star Wars
series which will be she write and show
run sort of an action thriller with a
martial arts element and set in an
alternative timeline from the usual Star
Wars universe what does that mean I'm
not entirely sure although it'd be
fascinating if they ever didn't I get
what if in the Star Wars universe ooh
Disney Plus yeah there's easy money
laying there right there on the table
let Marvel do their what if and then let
them do what ifs : Star Wars yep a
season down the road I like the way you
program your network
it's one half-hour show for you guys
I've done so good away from my thyroid
treatment what else and the last bit of
news is that were you were you a fan of
the st. the the Roger Moore oh the saint
a saint I thought you said descent
descent and I was like was that a combo
character doesn't know about lucky
stanker smells I don't like that
low-hanging fruit wait a second the
saint the Saint Simon Templar Simon
Templar originally played by religion
later on played by Val Kilmer in a movie
with Elisabeth Shue you know I'm not
familiar with this character at all
don't know what you mean they're doing
the Saints again they're doing the
Saints again who's doing it
Parramatta is doing it once more our boy
Dexter Fletcher oh he's good yes he's
good is directing and Chris Pine is
going to play Santa Claus [ __ ] me in the
mouth I was about to not [ __ ] on it
because I think we need another safe but
you ever I will watch Chris Pine in
anything I think he's a fantastic
[ __ ] actor yeah and not just like oh
he's great as Steve Trevor and [ __ ] like
go back to smokin aces mmm haven't seen
that moving forever
he's got like this keys he's the crazy
new guy in the movie where like who the
[ __ ] is this kid he's brave [ __ ]
actor and stuff and still is man he's
wonderful charming his [ __ ] did you ever
see him hosting SNL set one sketch where
him I think it's like Mikey day like
there's a the cops on a stakeout and
like on one room it was a guy and
they're like we're watching him he's got
gonzo like what's what else is going on
and they pan over to another set of
windows and it's like it's Chris Pine
and Mikey day and they're like dancing
and eating cotton what do you see and
he's like I don't know how did his best
way to describe it is they're having a
cotton candy party he's like two dudes
just stoked as hell enjoying cotton
candy with each other and they're like
like is this a gay thing and he's like
no it's just kind of like a 12 year old
boys having a sleepover and then he's
like what's happening now he's like oh
there's an update and he's like and one
of them it's Chris Pine he puts on a
backpack and pretends to walk down a
[ __ ] catwalk and he goes I think
they're having what you might call a
backpack fashion show right now he was
[ __ ] legit funny man he's so good and
everything so I you know what I was
about to be like st. they've done it but
with that guy yeah I'm in yeah I
re-examined my feelings about Chris Pine
with hell or high water he was great in
that he's amazing that because the first
time I some I forgot smokin aces or
maybe didn't register smokin aces but it
was Captain Kirk right over start
records and I loved his Kirk as he he
didn't do an impression of Shatner but
he definitely had the essence of [ __ ]
Kirk dead totally but I was like oh no
it's a good performance but it's Star
Trek there's so much else happening it's
not it's not a movie about acting yes
he's not you know hey can you hold the
screen yeah no basket being charming
it's about being charming but hell or
high water is like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] is
this guy he's got legit chops so if he's
gonna if he's gonna dig into the saint
and he also feels like a guy who's
willing to have fun and then as a rolled
calling for fun and the premise of the
saint is he's he's a it's a bit like he
was raised in an orphanage
and it was a like crazy Catholic
orphanage so every alias that he takes
in his world as a like international
rogue bounty hunter slash do-gooder like
you would get these missions and it was
always to like save somebody who help
somebody and even donate that whatever
proceeds to orphanages around the world
but he would always his aliases would
always be named after saints and so you
know Simon Templar being I suppose his
first floor the Knights Templar is the
one that he just kind of sticks with but
everybody else would be you know bare
abyss blah blah blah and this guy in
that game and he was just like a rich
guy crimes right rich guy crimes it was
always like I'm going to infiltrate
hearings now the jewel of India and then
give it to whatever I just remember
being a kid and when it came on I'd be
like oh can't they just play cartoons
why must i why it's it's it's James Bond
but he's not James Bond James Bond like
on a shoestring budget yes who's like
rather than a Ferrari he drives a Volvo
even as a kid I was just like he says
this is a Kmart James Bond telling me
this before he was James Bond that show
I think got him the job as James Bond no
because it was Sean Connery George
Lazenby and then they were like hey the
guy who played the saint he was good
years later there was another dude who
was on TV on a show where people were
always like wow he would have been great
as a James Bond old Pierce Brosnan and
then he got to be [ __ ] James Bond you
love it when [ __ ] works out and like it
wouldn't work out because he was penned
down to Remington Steele he couldn't get
out of his contract
they went to Timothy Dalton and they're
like well you do James Bond for a while
and then it came back around to Pierce
Brosnan it's like I'm ready I can go and
cinah the Dalton wound up being the
chief in Doom Patrol
just keep it on brand for bad guy The
Rocketeer he was the bad guy Rocketeer
man he was like an arrow Clint he played
essentially like their Errol Flynn
knockoff yeah he's so good in that mood
got that movie's good it is and nobody
really talked about I think I saw some
[ __ ] where there's like a new rocket to
your cartoon yeah is there yeah I think
it's on the Disney Plus but it not it's
not it's not Kyle Steve I think Kyle
Seager there might be like an old
lipstick on cliff Secord left Secord an
older cliffs and Kofi was you know alan
arkin yeah but I think the the comics it
was Betty Page was his girlfriend but in
the movie was a Jenny Blake or something
yeah Jenny Blake got a lot though
remember [ __ ] it where's da rocket
[Applause]
yeah I just remember being struck for a
number of reasons by Jennifer Connelly
who I was like oh no she's a little girl
she's not the little girl from the
labyrinth anymore
yeah she's wonderful in that movie too
Hawkman that movies good and and so I
mean it's it's funny cuz when you know
it's very true to the Dave Stevens stuff
Dave Stephens like Rocketeer arc was
stunning just beautiful his books were
so fantastic and he was like kind of
single-handedly responsible for bringing
Betty Page back like into the
mainstream cultural mainstream by making
your character in the book and stuff but
in the books it's a single-engine rocket
and in the comics in the in the movie
it's a dual engine rocket that looks
more like a backpack and if you look
really closely in Jay and Silent Bob
strike back when we're in the blunt cave
and Silent Bob goes like this and gets
the blunt saber to him to have a fight
with [ __ ] [ __ ] knocker hanging on the
wall like where the blunt saber is is
The Rocketeer pack mmm because this was
a rat face our production designer was
going like you know should we check it
out with like all sorts gadgets like the
Batcave I said yeah he goes if we could
get other movie tech I was like
absolutely so you can rent The Rocketeer
pack out of a prop house you know it's
like in a perfe in a better more fair
world that [ __ ] did being a museum you
know what I'm saying cuz it was in like
like you better believe I couldn't rent
the Infinity Gauntlet from a prop house
you know what I'm saying like [ __ ] dad
that movie made billions it's going into
Museum and [ __ ] but I was as much as I
was delighted to get my hands on the
Rocketeer pack for just the background
shot I was so sad that I'm like no like
you can't rent this out this belongs to
cliff Secord
lulu-nee what else we got
that's hit me marks beer is empty and
that means the show is over we could do
Q know if we want true do we have people
asking questions we'll do one q 9 days I
saw I saw the coolest thing driving in
to tell me I was on the 101 passing the
405 Californians speak you've seen this
kid I know what he's talking about these
numbers make sense to me and and I'm
pulling up past this this truck it's a
pickup truck with a with a cab on the
back it's yellow and it's got the it's a
Toyota truck but every other letter
except for the Y in the O or blanked out
like oh and that's interesting and I
pull up closer and then I start there's
there's a rocket ship mounted on the
hood of the of
a cab and then I see on the side of it
is it's painted Pizza Planet like some
dude cosplayed his [ __ ] pickup truck
as the pickup truck from Toy Story
and then the closer you get you see he's
got a little buzz lightyear doll in the
back window like I want to be friends
with this guy it worked her oldest thing
dude and he did pull off the 405 but I
was like we're gonna get can't take a
picture that's super and dangerous but I
got it this is so cool when we're
talking about the podcast you know how
like some people like I'm gonna make my
own Batmobile and do it and it looks
good and [ __ ] how many people you think
I like I'm gonna do my own Pizza Planet
yeah like that seems like something only
Disney would bother doing it's nice to
know that somebody out there is like I
love that joke so much so I want to live
that joke yeah like I don't know what is
danger maybe he's a [ __ ] clown and he
goes to kids parties and he pulls I'm in
the Pizza Planet truck he's like he's
like [ __ ] you guys I work at Pizza
Planet
they make me drive I don't want to drive
this man oh man all right you got a
question for us JC yeah this is from F
pop entertainment he was curious what
movie characters that haven't fought a
predator would you make a movie of
fighting the Predators aliens vs.
predator so like alien vs. predator bugs
to take out the alien no superhero
somebody vs. predator what movie
character in comics they did many times
dark horse I think MDC did Batman versus
Predator which is always kind of metal
but going off the discussion we were
just having I say Woody and Buzz a
predator can't win you can't kill those
[ __ ] toys they were they were almost
burned alive in the third one and sent
straight to hell and somehow they
[ __ ] lived so there's no way on earth
that the predator beats Woody and Buzz
you know because friendship is magic and
you got a friend in me and all that [ __ ]
and the predator just dies I mean they
beat that [ __ ] mean kid a blue [ __ ]
up with firecrackers which you know one
could argue that that's that kid wasn't
the villain no misunderstanding he's
very creative like he took toys rather
than play with the standard way so
you're gonna that new toys and [ __ ] but
no he's the bad guy make my own universe
in any event I say Woody and Buzz
that's an excellent answer thank you
mulder and scully I would drop the mic
but it's gonna hurt Andrews here so just
imagine what a great answer oh my god
mixing to [ __ ] and you could because
wait a sec no [ __ ] does that mean that
Disney owns the x-files yeah wow that's
that's a [ __ ] head scratcher alright
[ __ ] all that mmm so wait Disney owns
the x-files and predator yes Disney owns
predator now you really do an alien look
I was okay with all the Disney like the
Marvel stuff but like they own that do
they oh they do own aliens mm-hmm no
wonder everyone got upset just like we
don't want this move why it's good for
everybody
but look as long as they use them they
better put them to work but anyway they
could totally pull this off yeah oh no
property let me hear your story pitch me
you had your moment the elevator so much
you're living a pitch you've got 15
floors tell me a movie I think they they
and that makes total sense he comes from
space printed across always like the
truth is out there they get a [ __ ]
call it's it's a cop procedural at the
end of the day just a bad guy
how do they defeat a black oil if they
give him the black oil and then he's
like and then he's got to get the [ __ ]
yeah I think then they hit him with that
one knife that you can only kill with
the black oil people I mean I think the
other thing you could do is you could
have like the x-files Avengers where
they like go back into the files and
find the like the aliens or the [ __ ]
weird ass [ __ ] that could defeat the
predator it's like finally tombs find me
this guy find me the dude who does the
spontaneous combustion guy you just
might be the blue dude calm assurance
when you said tombs I love that that's a
good idea so it's like a [ __ ] you
bring back all the worst villains and
[ __ ] what was that what was Brad Dourif
Snape he was the killer remember like it
was in jail and her dad dies and then
he's like her dad like cuz he could
channel people and he's like starbuck
and she's like
hmm bring that [ __ ] back yes
tooms is that the it's a guy who could
like squeeze into Texas yeah yeah yeah
and also the [ __ ] this parasite
looking [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah he back those
inbred [ __ ] from in the
basement from home from home yeah
they'll [ __ ] beat the predator
predator [ __ ] yeah
predator we'll get one look at these
this family having sex with each other
and be like I'm leaving this planet no
don't want it no to this you have
defeated me sir I like yours good pole
alright great answers give us another
one this is going well this Andrew
Phillips says of all the dune quotes and
your Philip says why do I have two first
names yeah
anyway sorry back to you of all the dune
quotes what's the best dune quote of
them all how the best dune quote but
what is the metric for best yeah and
what is dune like is it the book or is
it the movie it wasn't not very specific
let's I think we probably can go movie
for me best movie quote of from dune
it's a toss-up between I will kill him
delivered like at the top of his lungs
for some reason or father the sleeper
has awakened is awoken or awaken awaken
awakened that's my version of dune he's
like on the giant worm he's like the
sleeper eyes are woken or is it awaken
waken awoken I'm gonna do it again
alright is sleeper and when I say the
sleeper and then I tell a long anecdote
my childhood yeah I mean it's fears of
mine killer is a quick and easy one but
I am still always been fascinated by my
name is a killing word
that's good lunch is super cool at
Shawnee Modi we've deep deep my my aim
is a killing word are they gonna do that
you think in I've read an article where
it's like there's very little to no
crossover with Lynch's doom but then
they also pointed out a bunch of movies
that Denny has done that has a Lynch
influence anyway or something like that
yeah I mean the the whole weirding way
thing wasn't in the books at all is that
right yeah
so who David Lynch created them here so
they leave that out of this right um
probably unless it's the thing that he
liked is like oh hey that's [ __ ] cool
we gave him guns that are weird made of
sound and that's neat and it makes him
special it had been in the books it's
the Fremen were just like the Israelis I
think was the closest analogy which is
they're constantly beset on all sides by
enemies so they've become so sharp and
so fierce that they they as a fighting
force are better prepared to handle
anything else than anybody else but they
didn't have like space magic at all the
that probably came from we gotta sell
some toys got some guns and [ __ ] he's
and that's a David Lynch gun it looks
like a flashlight and you yell at it
like also they're gonna love it they
make them man legit made into us because
they were like we get some of that Star
Wars money in the universe was like no
you're not nobody wants these yeah can I
make a toy of the big [ __ ] third-stage
traveler that looks like two giant
testicles with a vagina mouth because
I'd like to sell that to a six-year-old
they didn't make that figure no they did
make the Baron Harkonnen like in the
major Batman with his [ __ ] up skin and
[ __ ] like that like that by the giant
penis dad I just wanted a bit in your
face just a luster petal that might be
one of my favorite lines Man 2 it's the
delivery though it's not so much the
line it's it's how that was delivered
everyone really went for it in that
movie yeah there's no half measures in
the film ain't no half-stepping
nope what do you got give us one more
Robert is interested to know if you were
to teach a course on storytelling
what's the syllabus meaning what movies
would you ask them to read they would
watch my version of endgame I'll tell
you that much
I'd be like kids don't believe what
you've heard and don't believe your
hearts let me tell you how this scene
really plays in my mind what would I
include the movies that inspired me for
sure so slacker I would include on the
syllabus Reservoir Dogs Trust do the
right thing
Last Temptation of Christ JFK Jaws a man
for all seasons those are the movies I
would include why I don't know because I
don't make movies like that but those
are the ones that inspired me I would
show them I would be forced to show them
clerks number one I made it but number
two it's like oh my god like this is the
movie that you show a bunch of [ __ ]
people that want to be in something want
to be filmmakers because it's like this
counted like if this [ __ ] counts you
could totally be a [ __ ] filmmaker so
I'd probably could include clerks not
for like selfish reasons but just like a
man the [ __ ] this is a low-budget
classic and then there would be a lot of
podcasting I'll tell you that much
because you can learn to be a
storyteller in that medium before you
jump into a very expensive medium and
try to tell a story and stuff so I'd be
having them do podcasts so that I can
listen to a mobility scats they're
storytellers now they're just gonna have
to do it with cameras and stuff yeah
that's about it what about you not a ton
of reading I don't think yeah really I
mean [ __ ] you wanna be a director it's
like yeah I mean there's there's a
handful all you have to do is read the
clapboard what take we're on and let's
be honest some first ad will probably
tell you that you know how to do that
but I think Syd field screenplay was a
book that I read very early on and
that's purely just how does it look how
does a screenplay look and if you
haven't read a lot of screenplays then
that especially when we were coming up
access to screenplays was hard yeah by
that book just like oh this is what it
looks
at least give you the language to be
able to discuss it Oh third act first
leg plot points that sort of [ __ ]
there's a book called the heroic journey
by Christopher Vogler which is very much
the the Joseph Campbell stuff but broken
down in a way easier to read way using
movies that you know as examples Star
Wars being chief among them but talking
about things like the the threshold the
heroic you know has to answer the call
and refuse the call and and those sort
of mythic archetypes that that that are
really helpful to tell this to kind of
stories that I like to tell which is you
know science fiction fantasy and and
heroic adventures a lot is really
helpful but movies wise rabies Lost Ark
ice do the right thing nice Goodfellas
nice Robocop who I want to go to here we
get to watch a fun of Donna Fogg
conflict aliens social network matrix
are you big social network hi I'm a huge
Sorkin guy yeah and social network
what about Molly's game Molly's game is
like the fifth van Halen album which is
like I really like van Halen it doesn't
matter if this is like not great van
Halen it's still van Halen alright
there's gonna be one song we're a team
and I think it's totally watchable movie
man really it really fun and she's
gained and is great and he keeps it
moving it's got an energy yeah I mean
it's and that's the first one he
directed right yeah yeah but I mean it's
note that the script is not as good as
even Steve Jobs or social network it's
not the movie that that a few good men
is at all but you know it's still like
hey I'm sure I'll watch this over motion
yeah The Shining woo good pull
yeah I mean it's it's some Kurosawa in
there probably you know Seven Samurai
maybe they're just chosen for the
audience you know named Robin I can I
throw a book in the syllabus yeah Rick
Schmidt wrote a book called feature film
making it used car prices mmm tells you
how to make a movie for six thousand
dollars well so that's it was incredibly
useful for me when I was making films
and it still holds up today because now
you can make
movies with $6,000 like back then it was
like could you imagine well if you
buckled down hard you can now you could
shoot a [ __ ] movie on your iPhone for
like 6,000 bucks
yeah like when I when I was first
starting out you know or first wanting
to do this in like the mid 90s there was
there's a ton of screenwriting books out
there as I'm sure there are now but
after a while you can read as many as
you want and you'll glean less and less
from them
true but one of them that I loved and
because it was less how to write
screenplays but it was the first time I
got paid for it which was a book of
interviews with filmmakers about their
first jobs and and it was fascinating to
read because again it's first-person
stuff it's here's what it was like for
me and they had a chapter before them
James Cameron talking about he was
writing Rambo First Blood Part two the
same time he was writing aliens because
they were both open assignments and he
just took them both he's like I don't
know if I'm ever gonna get to do this
again I walked into [ __ ] Fox and
there was a big sheep who's I got Simon
she did a high school for the play it
was like and I saw aliens was on there
and I'm like alien sequel [ __ ] it yeah
I'll do that
and then he gets a call from like
golan-globus so whoever was making Rambo
2 and so just his his work ethic
first and foremost but just the way he
would like I could write both of these
ER wants and I'm giving myself you know
I've got 16 weeks when they're both due
I'm giving eight weeks for one eight
weeks for the other not just ping pong
between the two I'll put on different
music for each movie so I can get into a
different headspace but like listening
to the way people who do this for a
living solve those problems I thought
was fascinating that is that would be
useful if you were trying to get in and
stay or even them now I'm in and that
sounds useful and [ __ ] alright there it
is Kevin marks film school syllabus yeah
there it is now you don't even need us
anymore now you know what's on the
syllabus itself study kids do it at home
what do they call it now when he's
learning on distant virtual learning
we're just learning yeah you'll
virtually learn with Kevin mark there it
is folks what a show it was fun
remember [ __ ] Steve JP was on ER show
that's how we started this show like how
unbelievable is that good get as guest
and then we have good talk
this good talk that this show is a
microcosm of the world in itself we
remember that thing we just did an hour
and a half ago yeah I forgot we did that
a lifetime ago hope you've had a good
time hanging out with us folks we love
doing this so we love that you guys tune
in when you do whenever you got you up
to it and stuff
I finished twilight of the Mallrats this
week outstanding my first draft of that
and it's it's certainly for this crowd
I'll tell you that much
so I'm more about that as we move
forward but now I'm going to read while
I'm waiting for reactions on Mallrats
and stuff I'm doing going into moose
jaw's and doing a rewrite there I'm
trying to be very I'm trying to be Jim
Cameron productive do it you know what
I'm saying cuz it worked out for him now
come out the box Rick
but there's everything to look forward
to for may the fourth Star Wars day what
day is that
it's a [ __ ] Star Wars Day falls on a
Monday don't you hate that it's a leap
year this year was a leap year so it
should have been on Sunday ah but they
got pushed a month like in leap years so
on Monday and that's only what does say
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday God we
gotta get off the air now I'm just
counting [ __ ] days three or four days
from now doesn't matter anymore it's
relevant tune in for the live stream
scum and villainy x' social media will
get you there and watch me and Mark do
our commentary track for the Empire
Strikes Back
we'll see if we saw the same movie or if
Mark saw the real movie and I made up a
better version in my head when Yoda is
holding out three fingers what does that
mean yeah that was him [ __ ] telling
him all hope is lost
[Laughter]
thanks for being here man it's always
fun to do the fat man Beyond here at the
scum and villainy Cantina we thank JC
for opening up for us do it Andrew for
what do you do over there [ __ ] button
puncher over there without him Boris
he's the guy making him show he puts the
he's the Steve JP of the show he
distributes it to you man
to put it in terms you now understand
cuz we had Steve geppi on the show early
he JEP ease it he jet B's it oh my god
he turned his name into a verb I'm smart
you're such a good writer but we got no
show whatsoever without the man to my
left give it up for the great Mark
Barnard Oh
I'm Kevin Smith sweet sweet man if you
want to catch me I'll be at that Kevin
Smith Club calm if you want to come over
there and join and stuff like that if
not don't worry about it man SModcast
Jane's a Hollywood babble-on
and fat man beyond still out there in
the world obviously you didn't have to
join to watch this at all and [ __ ] like
that membership has its privileges so
thank you for hanging out with us here
tonight ladies and gentlemen for fat man
beyond I am Kevin Smith and I am mark
Barnard tune in next time same that time
same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith I wanted
to better I was going to say for the
good of all Creek but I watched a movie
and they had a better line in it where I
was like oh I got to remember that I'm
such a [ __ ] stoner I didn't write it
down so what's a good like [ __ ] comic
book line like you know it's always
darkest for the dawn that's not what's a
good line because I also think about for
the good of all creel Ike they turned
out to be shitty in the end they really
did so I don't know why I signed off
with that it took me a few months but
I'm like perhaps I shouldn't sign up oh
here I know what I was watching
okay and having a [ __ ] blast cuz I
haven't watched it like in a year and
[ __ ] because you got to remember it
happened then all sudden
endgame happened as well [ __ ] I
rewatched black panther what a [ __ ]
amazing movie it really takes you on a
goddamn journey man it is so ambitious
and it lands it sticks every landing
it's so huge like that there's about
nine movies going on in that movie
so let's steal their [ __ ] sign off
okay and sakes
so for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith
I'm mark barnard and tune in next time
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube here comes us Kevin
Smith
well Conda for
pepper way to throw it back thank you
you